foreign hi everybody thank you so much
for tuning in to the September edition
of Ubisoft forward the Showcase where
you get a taste of all the great things
we're cooking up I'm one of your hosts
Neil and Kumar I'm Yusuf McGee and I'm
so happy to be here today because this
year we're Global streaming in no less
than 11 different languages so a big
hello to everyone around the world we're
also live in four sign languages and two
audio descriptions so we got you all
covered yo Mila I love this studio I
feel like we're big time now come a long
way from being interns I mean look it up
hey come on look at us look at us who
would have thought not me so let's get
to the real reason why we're here today
Gates if you caught the Ubisoft board
pre-show you should already be caught up
on some super exciting updates from
current releases and now in the next few
minutes we'll show you what you can
expect from our live and upcoming games
concluding with a very special
Assassin's Creed showcase in fact let's
check in with them right now
well hello everyone stay tuned for the
Assassin's Creed showcase coming up
later in the show we'll celebrate the
15th anniversary of this amazing
franchise and share the future of
Assassin's Creed so don't go anywhere
we'll be back soon
we'll be catching up with the Assassin's
Creed crew later in the show but we also
wanted to remind you that right now
you're all eligible for a three-month
subscription of Ubisoft plus giving you
access to some of our best games for
more information check the details on
the screen below and now on to the games
that's right and what a better way to
start the show than by diving straight
into the colorful world of Mario and the
Rapids this latest Adventure Mario plus
rabbit Sparks of Hope is set to release
on October 20th on Nintendo switch
before we catch up with the game's
creative director Davide soliani let's
take a quick look
thank you
[Music]
oh yeah
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone
a few months ago we gave you an
exclusive on Mario plus rabbits Sparks
of all showcasing the game's unique mix
of turn-based combat real-time action
and open exploration
we also did a deep dive on our unique
team of Heroes
I want to thank you so much for your
tremendous feedback and I know you now
want to see Morgan play
so today we are back to show you for the
very first time a first look at one of
the quests from the game including a
special battle that we took great
pleasure in crafting
hello everyone I'm Faye associate
producer welcome to this new video about
Mario plus Rabbids Sparks of Hope
today our heroes travel to terraflora in
their quest to save the Sparks
this green and usually flurry planet is
struck by a drought caused by curses
malevolent influence
go now
[Music]
to help the planet Blossom again Mario
and his friends must reach the top of
the volcano to get there they will have
to find their way to the central station
and take the wiggler train
Terra Flora like all the planets of
Mario plus rabbits parts of Hope is
packed with stickers Collectibles
together puzzles dissolved and wacky Yen
pieces to talk with
with the help of people Heroes can
interact with the environment in various
ways to uncover Secrets or reveal a
hidden path to new zones
there are many interesting places to
visit and secrets to discover on
terraflora giant trees Lush Plains and
hidden caves
let's get back on track
we have a train to catch
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
has been enraged by cursa and we must
stop it before it destroys the train
Mario and his friends will face numerous
enemy archetypes on the battlefield each
with specific strengths and weaknesses
we need to prepare accordingly
let's pick Bowser first his huge Health
pads will allow him to sustain heavy
damage
private Rosalina's signature technique
will be key to neutralize enemies while
the other Heroes focus on the darkness
eyes we'll keep Mario and the team to
take advantage of his great Mobility
skills
now the Sparks there are dozens of
Sparks you can pair with your Heroes
they will grant Elemental damage
resistances help control Battlefield and
much more ethering will help Robert
Rosalina getting Behind Enemy Lines to
wreak havoc
[Music]
we're done prepping so now is the time
to fight
let's activate Mario spark Equinox to
gain additional Splash damage thanks to
the splash effect Mario can push the
user out of the train while he destroy
the electric barrel with his second
attack
rabbit Rosalina can finish the Uber off
while Bowser takes advantage of the
large attack radius of his baozuka to
destroy two Darkness eyes at the same
time
fast forward new enemies are scoring
behind us
we must get rid of them quickly
let's use Mario spark glitter to lure
those enemies out into the open before
triggering Mario's signature ability
hero side
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
it's time for Bowser to get his revenge
he's lending damage ability combined
with the devastating power of zephyr
break his chocolate spark and Mario
support fire will make short work of
this group of enemies
[Applause]
teamwork and synergies are key to gain
the upper hand in battle
that the back of the train is clear we
must reach the locomotive to destroy the
darkness eyes on the Wiggler's back
these won't be easy as the lawn walls
will react by shooting any moving hero
coming into range
heavy damage to Bowser thankfully
exosphere is shieldsberg absorbs some of
the damage
Brute Force won't make it here it's time
for a stealthy move with Robert Rosalina
a spark ethering can turn her invisible
allowing her to approach the Long Walk
safely
now that we are close to them we can use
his signature technique and neutralize
their momentarily
[Music]
this will allow Mario to approach safely
and focus on the darkness eyes
[Music]
turnza has only two Darkness eyes remain
but new powerful enemies have spawned
and even Bowser cannot withstand their
powerful attacks we have only two Heroes
left and the last Darkness eyes are far
out of attack range
but Mario can count on his iconic stomp
attack and jump from one enemy to the
other before delivering the final blow
this is it the wiggler is defeated and
our heroes can resume the journey I hope
you enjoyed this very special battle
that's all for now
I hope you also enjoyed seeing an old
friend from Nintendo in there
this was only a first taste of our new
take on combat it has intuitive gameplay
with huge tactical possibilities
thanks to the multiple combination of
Sparks and ingredients available in the
game anyone can create combos as
marvelous as they are powerful
the release is almost there and we are
hard at work to polish our game and
deliver the best Mario plus rabbits
experience on October 20. we cannot wait
for you all to discover this brand new
adventure
and that's not all we have one more big
thing to review
this Cosmic Journey will not stop at
lunch we have so many wild ideas that we
want to explore in the coming year it is
a bit early to announce all of it but I
couldn't resist to give you a small Peak
at what is to come
our first lunch plans include three DLCs
and the third one will even introduce a
new special
playable eel for me as a Creator and for
Mania the studio it's a dream come true
to have him going in an adventure with
our dear rabbit Heroes
I hope you will like the biggest
surprise of our season pass thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I love the rabbits and I love the world
of Mario and I'm so glad to see them
teaming up once again Davide is so
passionate about what he creates and I
can't wait to play his Rayman on my team
in this new DLC Adventure if you like
what you just saw I want to dive into
the conversations online just use
hashtag ub4 it's up there on the screen
now back in July we revealed the new
direction of skull and bones and since
then the team at Ubisoft Singapore has
been hard at work getting the game ready
for launch let's take a deep dive into
the world of skull and bones
the end of the 17th century when
ruthless corporations ruled the Seas
with an iron fist
they ignited a battle for Global
Supremacy to dominate the world's most
valuable trade rooms
a flood of exotic goods from the Indian
Ocean stormed the West
creating new Addictions on a final price
of control
and where there's blood there are
predators
labeled as enemies of all mankind
Miss Newbury of pirates will show no
sailing for Dangerous Waters they
created secret trading networks and
built their pirate Empires
but they were always on the edge of
losing it all
and sink Into the Depths a skull and
bones
will you sing to the bottom or climb to
the very top is a Don Jose and bonds
every single on you is either your prey
or you don't follow this is where you
and your friends will have a notantic
pirate experience
in our game as joint family begins to
spread across the Indian Ocean you will
gain access to your own pirate layer
known as the helm
here you Kickstart your Ascent as a
pirate Kingpin by manufacturing and
smuggling illegal and high value Goods
to sell to the highest bidder no longer
taking orders from other Pirates will
now be the one calling the shots but
with all the riches now for you taking
you'll also have more to lose so beware
the virtues are cycling biding their
time to strike you down will you fend
off pirate rocks in your cargo as you
extract your Contraband or undone Rivals
who want a piece of your pie maybe
you'll plan their thoughts for the
stockpiles and flew the black markets or
even go on Treasure Islands to dig up
valuable hidden stashes we've been
Gathering your feedbacks through our
Insider programs and other channels it's
an ongoing process that helps us shape
skull and bones here is what some of our
participants have to save as a program
greetings Pirates Captain Flynn here my
name is Sam more commonly known as Mr
stainless I'm real Dean I'm Fazbear my
name is my name is hippo TC my name is
mixopics this is charging Charlie crispy
tater tot here I joined these skull and
bones inside the program back in 2021.
I've actually been part of The Insider
program ever since its Inception I have
sailed plundered and pillaged my way
through multiple testing and feedback
sessions the play tests that I've been
doing have been a lot of fun one of the
things that I enjoy about it the most is
the streamlined feedback actually
reaching the developers the developers
are passionate about this game I get to
connect with other Gamers you're just as
passionate and excited about Skull and
Bones as I am happy to see the game
being revealed again I'm so excited
we're just months away I look forward to
seeing your sales out there I truly
think that's something for everyone so
I'm really eager to see all the Polish
and final versions of things brought
into the game I just can't wait to see
all the Indian oceans and I'm really
looking forward to seeing all of you out
on the high seas be it Friend or Foe
a parrot's work is never done as your
feet grows so will our game as in the
para Tales of old you will always find
your ship at the center of the story
once so terrifying that Moss will be on
site that is what we want for our
parrots your ship is your entire world
it is where your success will be decided
and how you will be recognized in skull
and bones to build a unique ship that
inspires fear onto your enemies there
are three steps step one pick your
weapons and ammo this will make or break
your battles from personal mode that
ignores armor and causes floating to
cheering almost that rips your enemy
sails apart slowing them down for an
easy kill my favorite is crushing as it
deals a devastating blow to most ammo
step two choose your armor with our
games weapon control system there will
be a number that can control each damage
type that's how we keep tension high at
sea
lastly it's a look of your ship but on
your scariest wall paint and head out
with a ship that is instantly
recognizable making this quick
adjustment will transform you from
sneaky Smuggler to Hardy thing enters or
Swift Traders
now when you are out in the open sea
it's always best to have a friend or two
to watch your back
in our pvvp world you can choose to
switch off PVP to prevent any Friendly
Fire as well lastly our game will be
cosplay as lunch so you can parachute
with your friends no matter what
platform they are on earth
and see you all soon on the Seas of
scoring bones
this could be the greatest Heist ever
and you Kali will play the villain
ready your ship
your loins
foreign
Destiny is calling
our names on her lips
[Applause]
I can't wait to get in my own pirate
ship explore the Indian Ocean and hunt
you down and steal all your loot gee I
love you too it's out of love it's out
of love skeleton bones are released this
year on Xbox series PS5 and PC all right
we're on to the next title
writer's Republic is our massively
multiplayer outdoor sports game for
players mountain bike snowboard ski and
wingsuit in Epic races and awesome
freestyle events but you know what Neil
just when you thought it couldn't get
any better we've added an exciting piece
of new content take a look at this
foreign
[Music]
writers Republic season 4 and the BMX
add-on launches in just four days on
September 14th and guess what you can
play writers Republic for free on all
platforms details are below
now it's time to put the spotlight on
one of our most successful online action
role-playing games yep it's time to
catch up on the world of Tom Clancy's
The Division
hello everyone I'm Daria Elena Community
developer for Tom Clancy The Division II
after more than three years Tom clances
the division 2 is still releasing new
content and we have exciting times ahead
to recap season 9 hidden Alliance
brought you so much more than just a
continuation of the story We introduced
countdown and no new 8-layer PV and game
mode plus a brand new progression
feature expertise giving you new ways to
progress your agent and further increase
build variety and viability
and it's not over the division 2 is
scheduled to receive two more major
Updates this year season 10 and season
11. you will be able to enjoy season 10
Price power in just a few days it will
introduce additional difficulty modes
for countdown to push your squad to the
Limit add an array of long-awaited
quality of life changes and set you on
the path to uncover the growing alliance
between Natalia Sokolova and General
Anderson and when it comes to ensuring
your agent looks the best for the new
Manhunt we've got you covered
Shea Paragon and dark path April events
are packed with a variety of new outfits
and vanity to give your agent a unique
look to close out 2022 for the division
2 season 11 will continue the diversion
story not only introducing new Manhunt
targets but it also some familiar faces
and a new ally it will also feature a
brand new PVE mode expanding the variety
of activities and playability in the
game we'll share more details about all
these features later this year
now we want to retaliate our commitment
to the long-term future of the division
2 which is fully supported by our
talented developers from Ubisoft teams
across the globe with this in mind we're
happy to announce that we are committed
to and have started working on the
division year 5. the future is pride for
the division 2 and for the division
franchise as a whole
now I'll hand over to Kerry to introduce
you to Tom Clancy the division's
heartland
over the last few years the team at Red
Storm entertainment has been hard at
work creating an all-new experience set
in the world of the division you've
already rebuilt operations in Manhattan
you've responded to the call in
Washington D.C and now you're needed in
the small town of Silver Creek right in
the heartland of America
today we're excited to share a first
look at the game and some updates from
our studio here's our creative director
Keith Evans to tell you a little bit on
what to expect in the division Heartland
hey everyone we're so excited to show
you Heartland in all new Standalone
Adventure in the division universe
the teams poured their heart into this
game and we can't wait to share it with
you
[Music]
welcome to Silver Creek
I'm Keith Evans creative director in
Heartland at Red Storm entertainment
we've been involved here at Red Storm
with the division going back before the
first game launched our partnership with
massive entertainment made some games
that we love we're so excited to bring
something new to fans of the franchise
heartlands of free to play Survival
action shooter set in the division
universe that features streamline
survival gameplay and a beautiful new
world to explore
you play as a division agent given the
task of protecting Silver Creek a small
town in Middle America from enemy
factions Rogue agents and a deadly
contamination this game ties directly
into the timeline and introduces all new
characters and story lines to the
franchise
Heartland feels fresh and distinct while
still feeling at home alongside the
other amazing games in this universe
we can't wait to have you join us in
Silver Creek
local division social channels to learn
more about the journey the team has
taken and the important role of player
feedback and the evolution of the
Heartland experience and register now
for upcoming tests at the
divisionheartland.com finally a few
weeks ago we welcomed a new entrance in
the division franchise on mobile the
division Resurgence this new Opus brings
the acclaimed AAA experience to mobile
with the addition of a new storyline
factions and much more the team is hard
at work preparing what comes next so it
is our great pleasure to be able to give
you an update on the game we wanted to
take a moment to thank everyone who's
participated in the closed Alpha playing
Solo or cooperating with others to
complete a taste of the game's unique
campaign and open world activities your
feedback has been priceless as we keep
fine-tuning and improving the game today
we're happy to announce that a close
beta test is coming this fall
this will be an opportunity to play the
iconic conflict PVP modes and for the
first time on mobile the dark Zone we
leave you with a look at the trailer
thank you
brother
we're super excited to see the dark Zone
coming to mobile if you want to get a
chance to test it out don't forget to
register now on the Resurgence website
oof I want that sweet sweet multiplayer
action in the palm of my hands speaking
of which there's another iconic
multiplayer game that was recently
announced Rainbow Six mobile let's take
a quick look at what the dev team
happens store for us following their
successful closed Alpha test
foreign
[Music]
foreign
hello everyone I'm Justin Swann creative
director of Rainbow Six mobile
it's been a big exciting year for our
game with the worldwide announcement and
our first close Alpha taking place
earlier this year it was amazing finally
getting to see how our players and
Community reacted to the game and we
couldn't be happier with the initial
feedback
Rainbow Six mobile is a free-to-play
game designed from the ground up
specifically for mobile devices when we
started production our objective was
crystal clear to bring the Rainbow Six
Universe to the mobile platform and
allow more people than ever before from
all around the world to enjoy this
competitive tactical and team-based FPS
experience
our mission is to develop the best
Rainbow Six experience possible on
mobile and we can only do that with your
help
the dev team and I first want to thank
our community for all your support and
feedback during our close Alpha we took
that feedback to heart and we've made
many improvements and it's not just the
core gameplay but our menu systems and
user experience matchmaking and round
around flow and many other adjustments
that will improve the overall experience
all thanks to you and now today I'm very
happy to announce that we are entering a
new phase for Rainbow Six mobile the
beta test
the closed beta starts this Monday
September 12th and the good news is that
Android users can still pre-register on
Google Play for a chance to participate
just a quick note for iOS users don't
worry we are working hard on our iOS
version and you will hear from us in the
near future for upcoming tests
so what can you expect to see in the
game during the beta test
our biggest addition is the first stage
of our operator unlock and progression
system this means daily challenges to
complete a ticket system to play with
and unlock your operators and even a
battle pass to progress through on top
of that we have some great graphical and
gameplay improvements social features
like voice chat and persistent teams and
a more streamlined menu flow you will
also be able to compete in three iconic
Rainbow Six Maps Bank border and the
newly added Clubhouse
keep in mind this is still a work in
progress version of the game graph
quality and content are much improved
from our Alpha test but still not final
as we continue along this exciting road
to release we must move forward
alongside you our players and fans we
believe this is the only way to deliver
the best game experience possible and we
are dedicated to developing Rainbow Six
mobile and as transparent and
collaborative way as possible with our
players
now you may be wondering in which
countries the closed beta will be
available starting this Monday well
you'll find the answers in this next
video
thank you for all your support and see
you in the closed beta
I'm ready
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
the Rainbow Six mobile closed beta
starts on September 12th here at Ubisoft
we're developing some world-class
Partnerships with some very big players
in the industry here to tell you a
little bit more about it is a very
special guest
hi I'm Mike Perdue from Netflix as you
know we've started to offer a selection
of mobile games on our service and today
I'm excited to announce our partnership
with Ubisoft to continue bringing great
games for players all around the world
over the next few years not one not two
but three games from ubisoft's most
beloved franchises will become
exclusively available to Netflix members
the first game is Valiant Hearts 2 a
sequel to the award-winning first game
directed by the original core team and
available to play in January 2023
next up
the second installment of Mighty Quest
also coming to Netflix in 2023 and last
but certainly not least
fans of Assassin's Creed will be able to
immerse themselves in the Assassin's
Creed Universe through both a live
action series and an original mobile
game
we'll be sharing more details on each of
these titles as we get closer to Launch
the games will be ads free with no
in-app purchases and you'll find them on
the Netflix mobile app thank you to the
Ubisoft team for their partnership and
we're looking forward to Bringing these
great games to existing and new fans
alike
Ubisoft to Netflix now that's something
to celebrate and speaking of having
something to celebrate the next project
shows how video games have grown we
don't just play them we make movies
based on them and sometimes TV shows
about making them and on that note let's
take a sneak peek at season three of
Mythic Quest hello everyone at Ubisoft
forward I'm Rob mcelhenney writer
co-creator and star of Mythic Quest on
Apple TV Plus for those of you who've
seen the show we can't wait for you to
watch season three for those of you who
haven't seen Mythic Quest this is the
series for you it's a show about a fake
gaming company making a fake game but
produced by a real gaming company that
makes real game elements for our fake
game not to mention we have actors like
Ashley Burch who are real gaming
professionals even though they play fake
characters
foreign
you know what why don't you just watch
this teaser for season three it'll
explain everything a lot better than I
just did and in case you're wondering no
you don't need any new gear to watch
Apple TV plus you can literally watch it
on the same gaming console you play on
hope you enjoy
this is where the magic happens this is
my legacy a legacy I would like to say
whatever it's not my legacy where are we
with the expansion let's just be
reasonable adults no something bad is
gonna happen we'll get you in the
program at school local mq will pay for
it I think I gotta go it's Berkeley yeah
that's impossible
go ahead and cuff me
oh my god did I miss something we're
leaving you and Mythic Quest yeah yes no
yes yes
[Music]
now
let's talk about our future
no what we're not
gonna take the money
love love
yes I'm glad you're back you know
janitor I see a lot of things but you
have nothing to worry about there's
nothing like strange or nefarious going
on
[Music]
and even if there was you'd never know
it
um sorry wait what are you into the
metaverse hell yeah
Bobby where are you you're the one that
didn't want lines anywhere in the office
lines are so web one you don't want to
be in web one do you you gotta think big
hey Pop
stop sneaking up on me I've been
standing here alone for the last 20
minutes
we're explorers
innovators
creators it doesn't matter what I
believe about myself
what matters is what you believe about
yourself this this is the air brittlesby
wasn't buttons hello
hello no buttons anywhere help
ah
every morning there's a Halo pretty good
every morning
I really love Mythic Quest I'm so happy
the show got renewed for a season three
same here whether you've played every
Ubisoft game in existence or more of a
casual fan there's something for
everyone here at Ubisoft forward which
brings us to a very special offer that
we definitely haven't referenced before
check this out
if we told you that UBC makes the games
you know and love and that's only the
beginning of so much more it is all the
Assassin's Creed titles even
jump into
computers to test your skills and your
patience team up for co-op and tactical
games are the only way forward is
together
question your definition of Good and
Evil with some of the greatest villains
in gaming plan build and create new
worlds with Anno and the settlers
game night you don't have to worry about
tables being flipped
eat an adrenaline rush no need for
tickets or Insurance here and you
thought Ubisoft only made open worlds
and guess what try it all for free
starting now until October 10th hours
and hours of gameplay and more being
added every month with any games and
skull and bones available day one you
Ubisoft plus is available on PC laptop
and mobile devices try it now for free
at ubisoftplus.com
what an offer a free one-month trial to
Ubisoft plus where you can enjoy playing
some of our best games details as always
are below Neil you could fit a lot of
free games into one month you sure can
so be sure to sign up right now next up
we have an update that I know trackmania
fans are going to be excited about we
think you're really gonna like this next
trailer check it out
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
to the excitement of its 10 million fans
trackmania is back on consoles and
streaming platforms early 2003.
and the first bit of good news is that
cosplay and cross projection will be
available across all platforms PS4 PS5
Xbox One Xbox series stadia and Luna
is free to play with no micro
transaction but we do offer two premium
access that unlock even more social and
Community videos you will still expand
that same address on extraordinary
tracts big Solo or online with hundreds
of live opponents we have lots of
features to keep you racing there's a
new seasonal official campaign every
three months export events like the cup
of the day with thousands of players
the track of the day which highlights
our players creativity
and you can team up with your friends to
play in the Royal or ranked game modes
and that's not all trackmania is the
best place for creators to unlock their
full imagination with its undist
relating and Powerful Tech editor
featuring thousands of blogs and items
so it's PC launch two years ago the game
is stronger than ever with 280 000
tracks created by players worldwide
so great news is that these tracks will
be available from day one on the console
and Cloud versions
with trackmania clubs we are offering
deep social features within the game
with car skin customization private
rooms as well as campaigns and
competitions organized by the players
for the players
we're looking forward to renating the
complete Park Mania community in one
single world no matter where an audio
play starting early 2023 welcome to the
club
I love me some track Mania I can't wait
to hop online and play against all my
friends I'm sure the both of you will
have a great time well that was
unnecessary uh Moving On Let's Jam out
to our next release it's a Rocksmith
plus right oh it sure is Neelam if
you've ever dreamed of learning the
guitar Rocksmith plus is for you
[Music]
plus is the perfect tool to get me
started well if you're going to learn
guitar you should also practice your
dance moves you mean these dance moves
how could I forget well for those of you
who like tearing it up on the dance
floor like Yusuf our next game is right
up your alley this year get ready to
step into a new era of Just Dance let's
check out all the exciting surprises the
team's been working on
[Music]
thank you
hello everyone I'm Claire buong I and
I'm the senior producer on Just Dance
and I am Matthew Tomkinson creative
director
over the past decade Just Dance has
become a fan favorite around the world
whether it offers you an instant mood
boost a sense of community a creative
Outlet or a way to stay active dancing
is a form of expression that speaks to
everyone with this in mind our
passionate team has been hard at work on
the latest installment to bring you even
more ways to dance
this year Just Dance offers A Renewed
experience with a new art Direction user
interface and then optimize the
recommendation system that find
playlists and songs that fit your every
mood
we also invite you to discover brand new
characters and follow them into
immersive stories across Rich Visual and
musical universes inspired by the latest
it's an old time classics the game is
live at heart and it will continue to
evolve throughout the year with new
songs new game modes season and much
more there is always something exciting
happening in Just Dance
for starters for the first time ever in
Just Dance you can enjoy the new online
multiplayer experience that will allow
you to dance with whoever you want no
matter where they are
with this feature you can create private
groups of up to six people for online
dance sessions
let's check out this new mode together
here is the new homepage of Just Dance
where you can discover all the
activities the game has to offer let's
welcome our just dancers
hello everyone
as you can see you will be able to group
with your friends
interact with them with our new sticker
system and pick the songs you want to
party along
okay let's jump into the song If You
Wanna Party
[Music]
[Music]
great job everyone
let's take a look at this course
and the winner is
well done Elena the new score result
screen features the new detailed dancer
cards of course you will be able to
personalize your own
thanks everyone for joining this session
the first one of many more to come
when you enter Just Dance you will
always have someone to play with as you
will join one United Community gathered
at the same place
we can't wait for you to get your hands
on the game we'll leave you with the
first glimpse of some of the amazing
songs of this year in the Just Dance
2023 Edition
[Music]
[Music]
any excuse huh I mean it's called Just
Dance for a reason personally I can't
wait to play with all my friends around
the world and yes Neelam I have friends
around the world anyway just dance 2023
Edition launches this holiday season
allowing you to finally dance with your
friends wherever they are on the planet
as you might know 15 years ago we
released a game that changed the world
of video games with Assassin's Creed we
introduce the new gaming Universe
capable of transporting you back to the
Crusades as Altair took assassinations
to the next level and now thanks to you
15 years later the brand is more alive
than ever this is why we created a deep
dive into the world of Assassin's Creed
to show you where the brain is going in
the future and we even have several
surprises and announcements for you and
now who better to introduce a showcase
like this than our CEO Eve Imo
everyone and thank you for joining us
for this edition of Ubisoft for world
I would like to congratulate all Ubisoft
teams around the world for their
tremendous work bringing this incredible
games to life and to all the players
watching us
thank you for the passion you have for
our games creating memorable and unique
experiences is what drives us every day
speaking of passion for games we are
celebrating 15 years since the first
Assassin's Creed Altair Ezio Arno bayek
Cassandra ever many of you have lived
memorable moments with these characters
making its story your playground
learning challenging yourself and most
importantly having fun with your support
Assassin's Creed went beyond a
collection of games it helped shape the
face of the video game industry and
became an inspiration for players and
developers around the world
and now let's see what's next for this
fantastic universe
[Music]
are you ready for this
of course you are come on don't be shy a
little fancy suit impress you
don't let a thousand fancy suits impress
you
thorn in history science
two is the greatest enemies the captive
sorry mate
the emperor
and make even greater friends decent
work Leonardo
I'll just pick a fight
start a revolution
get the bigger picture
go too far
go too fast
[Music]
face the invisible
The Impossible the Unspeakable
welcome to the greatest playground
history
foreign
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome along to the
first ever Assassin's Creed showcase it
is time to LEAP into history I'm Danny
Wallace here in our top secret hideout
where I'll be bringing you some sneak
peeks special guests and sharing some
very exciting updates on all things
Assassin's Creed you will not want to
miss this today I am joined by a true
expert Assassin's Creed's senior
community developer ubisoft's own Alice
turret welcome to the show Alice can you
believe it's been 15 years thank you so
much Danny I cannot believe it's been 15
years it's a series very close to my
heart because I'm in it I'm lucky enough
to voice Sean Hastings who first
appeared Back In Assassin's Creed 2. now
Sean sounds exactly like me which may
give you a clue as to the limits of my
acting range this year we are
celebrating 15 years since the release
of the first Assassin's Creed it's been
an amazing journey with our community
that started back on the rooftops of the
Holy Land it has taken us to the Italian
Renaissance into the center of
Revolutionary War was to ancient worlds
and to many incredible places in between
we've met Unforgettable characters and
been to breathtaking locations allowing
you to LEAP into history and relive
pivotal moments from our past it's been
a phenomenal 15 years and we are so glad
that you came along for the ride
[Music]
for the 15-year anniversary of
Assassin's Creed we want to truly
celebrate with you our community we know
that you've been dying to find out
what's next for Assassin's Creed and so
uh just on that point it does sound a
lot like you're about to announce a new
game or something I am about to announce
a new game I just thought it'd be nice
to see as I'm here so anyways uh it's
time to discover what we've been
crafting in the shadows I hope you
brought a trailer at least I have roll
the trailer
foreign
are you ready to give up who you once
thought you were I am
[Music]
ready to sacrifice everything you have
clothes I am
what happened
[Music]
are you ready to leave your life behind
and walk the path of Shadows I am
oh
my God
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
to uphold
[Music]
stay your blade from the Flesh of the
innocent
hide in plain sight
never compromise the Brotherhood
what happened
[Music]
[Music]
from this day forward
you are a hidden one
[Music]
foreign
Mirage everybody and here to tell us
more why it is Ubisoft bordeaux's
narrative director Sarah thank you so
much for coming thank you for having me
Sarah we just had a little glimpse of
Mirage what can you tell us about this
latest and very special Assassin's Creed
Adventure well indeed it is special we
go back to the roots of this series it's
been 15 years as you know and wanted to
go back to the action adventure game
that you know narrative driven game
we've been focusing on stealthspokore
and of course assassinations
now I've been playing a lot of Valhalla
recently and from watching that trailer
I couldn't help but notice bassim yes
you're right it's passive it's 20 years
before Valhalla so it's a young Basim
there's gonna be coming from a street
Thief to a Master assassin fantastic and
and so where does his kind of Adventure
begin well it begins in Baghdad ah it's
the beautiful magnificent
city of Baghdad that you're gonna roam
through the game and it's um yeah it's a
very dense City where you're going to
meet a lot of different people that's
amazing I know our community has been
very excited to explore Baghdad um so
Sarah what can you tell us that makes
Mirage special to you specifically what
to me obviously it's all about the story
so as you saw we have a couple of
charismatic characters
starting from Basim so Basim is our lead
character we do have Russian that you
spotted in the trader she's basim's
Mentor we also have a lot of historical
characters like in every Assassin's
Creed so political leaders for example
but not not just we do have a couple of
very very interesting characters in
there well what a setting and what
history to get your teeth into but we're
obviously about exclusives here have you
got any more yes I do good and did you
recognize the voice from the trailer I
did actually can I can I can I reveal it
can I reveal it
it was the Emmy winning actress wasn't
it shory AG Dash Lou it was it was yeah
you got it right good yeah we're
thrilled to have her in the cast it's
gonna be gonna be praying Russian so
she's going to be
a bit Mentor that you serving the trader
actually and the whole team is very very
glad to have her she's fantastic such a
recognizable voice which is why I
recognize that of course well and we
were lucky enough to catch up with shory
earlier and she had this very special
message
hello everyone I am so real and I'm
thrilled to announce that I will be
voicing Roshan but it seems Mentor in
Assassin's Creed Mirage
when Ubisoft approach me to voice this
character I was immediately seduced by
Roshan's strong personality and her
backstory she's the true warrior who
fights for justice
protects her fellow hidden ones at all
costs
she is loyal and honest but keep her
form herself behind a shroud of Mystery
and of course the fact that she is a
mature woman from Persian Origins made
her resonate even more with my own story
and background
playing such a character is a unique
opportunity that I could not miss I hope
you will love her as much as I do it's a
real pleasure for me to collaborate with
the Assassin's Creed brand and play one
of the main characters in such an
anticipated new game
I am wishing you all a Happy AC 15th
anniversity
thank you all yours
sincerely sorry artist
what a nice message what a recognizable
voice as well just instantly and she
seems thrilled to be part of this yeah I
think she is really let's get a welcome
addition to the Assassin's Creed world
so finally obviously the question
everyone wants to know when can we get
our hands on Mirage assassin's marriage
is going to be available in 2023 and if
you pre-order now you also get the
exclusive 40 thieves side quests but
it's not all we also have a collector's
case available for pre-order as well it
includes a figurine of bassim and other
exclusive surprises that you will love
thank you Sarah for being with us today
thank you for having me thank you very
much yes it looks fantastic right we'll
be dropping more exclusive news from the
world of Assassin's Creed very shortly
but first we wanted to celebrate the
last 15 years of Assassin's Creed with
you let's remind ourselves of some of
the highlights and of course the impact
of this groundbreaking series
out of the dark you come into the light
from the light
turn to the dark
[Music]
are you prepared to travel to Eagle's
path
[Music]
welcome aboard
prizes plunder and Adventure ahead
[Music]
all different
different but our great will unify us
[Music]
[Music]
do you regret your decision to leave as
an assassin for so long
I do not remember making that decision
this life
it chose me
[Music]
what is a man but the sum of his memory
we are the stories we live the tales we
tell ourselves
gentlemen as his custom among Our Kind
do not plunge headlong into Folly on the
orders of a single Madman but act
according to our own
Collective Madness
[Music]
from Darkness we have come and in
darkness we shall we shall stay
we are the hidden ones
[Music]
it is a good life
[Music]
best they never change
[Music]
well so many memories there makes me
want to jump back in and just play
through the whole series again well
Danny to continue the celebrations we
also have a new documentary out today
which gives a behind the scenes look at
the last 15 years of Assassin's Creed
let's take a sneak peek
for me Assassin's Creed represents my
whole video game in the carrier
it's really like where I learned my job
where I grew in my job
that was really the game that showed to
me hey you gotta step it up but like you
gotta move on from the PS2 and I fell in
love ever since
Assassin's Creed especially in those
early days showing people what could be
done in this kind of broad open space
just like climbing up things and just
looking at this world and being like oh
wow I've never done this in a video game
before we're always looking for the next
Assassin's Creed no matter which one is
your favorite you'll always be tied to
it because of just how connected they've
kept you from the beginning it's not
just the game it has a philosophy behind
it it's a universe it's not just a
single setting in a single time but it's
different settings at different times
it's like a narrative universe that
comes to life
[Music]
well that looks worth a watch to me
where can we see it is it somewhere on
the internet yes it will be on the
internet uh you can catch it on the
Ubisoft and GTV YouTube channels but
don't go anywhere just yet no so back to
business and I've just finished the dawn
of Ragnarok expansion for Assassin's
Creed Valhalla had a great time but I
would like some more yep that's one of
our most ambitious expansion today but
Danny if you want more I've got great
news as we have more content coming to
Assassin's Creed Valhalla
hello everyone I'm Gareth Glover game
director on Assassin's Creed valhalla's
post launch since launch we've continued
to create new and exciting content for
our community to enjoy we've already
released new game modes and activities
into the world of Valhalla such as River
raids tombs of the Fallen Mastery
challenges and more recently the road
light forgotten Saga today I'm excited
to announce that in a few months time we
will also be launching the last chapter
so let's take an exclusive first look
[Music]
Odin
I feel you close
[Music]
an uproar of memories stretching far
into the past
I have done all I can for my people
it is time to say goodbye and set forth
for Distant Shores and new adventures
fascinating Ava grapples with Odin's
memories in a way unfamiliar to me
where will this new conflict take you I
wonder
[Music]
[Music]
the last chapter is a free questler
which nicely ties up some of the
storylines established throughout the
game we'll see avor reunite with some
key characters including some
influential historical ones we can't
wait for you to experience it back to
you Danny and Alice
you ready for some more exclusives no no
I'm not no I'm a little overwhelmed
already but please go on okay well our
next guest can do just that he's no
stranger to the Assassin's Creed family
with a list of credits including
creative director of Assassin's Creed
Syndicate and producer of Assassin's
Creed Odyssey I'm of course talking
about Mark alexicote Mac thanks for
joining us well thank you Alice it's
great to be here and I I love what
you've done with the place thank you so
let's start with our community can you
tell us what makes Assassin's Creed so
beloved by our Global Community well at
Ubisoft our mission as a company as
expressed by Eve is to enrich the lives
of players on Assassin's Creed we have a
very clear take on that mission we want
history to be everybody's playground as
we immerse players into the richness of
our shared past
what makes AC different though is this
kind of unique mix between historical
accuracy and contemporary codes like the
Animus and when you put all that
together it gives you the chance to
embody iconic characters to live
powerful fantasies all the while
immersed and intriguing uh historical
settings it's amazing so how will
Assassin's Creed evolve in the coming
years well we're gonna double down on
our passion for history as we explore
the past with courage uh we strongly
believe that uh history can be the most
powerful and eye-opening source of
entertainment
and our teams believe that history can
help us better understand the world that
we live in as so many elements from the
past still resonate with our present but
don't worry we're going to keep telling
Grand epic stories so that viewers and
players alike can feel the vertigo that
only human history can bring I love the
way you talk about history and about
using history as a playground what an
incredible thing to be able to use
history in this in this way but what
does this mean for fans going forward
well we want our passion for history to
fuel the expansion of the franchise into
new territories so I'm very happy to
announce today our very first open world
Assassin's Creed game for mobile it will
feature all the iconic Assassin's Creed
gameplay but optimize for an experience
on touch controls and I just can't wait
to tell you more about the story and the
setting that's taking look at the
trailer
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
game set in China it looks amazing Matt
can you tell us a little bit more about
the features well for the first time in
our opening world games you can create
your own character you'll get the chance
to do things like parkour Atop The Great
Wall of China sneak through bustling
cities engage in intense combat and
discover the secrets of vastness of
ancient China
well that leads me to my next question
so Mac many of us know that a Netflix
show is in development and the community
would like to know more what else can
you tell us well it's still early in
development but I can confirm that we
are co-developing the Netflix series
with Ubisoft film and television Netflix
obviously had an insanely talented
showrunner Jeb Stewart it's going to be
an epic jar bending a live-action
adaptation of our video game series but
that's not the only thing we have in
development with Netflix we also have a
new mobile game and development for
their platform wow so you're doing quite
a lot with Netflix and just out of
Interest there's no reason for me to ask
this this is just just curious a lot of
people probably want to know who who is
the casting director for that
well why do you want to know no I'm just
just that a lot of people have been
tweeting in about that well we'll put
his name on screen I'll talk to you
after about that in the meantime let's
take a look at the wider world of
Assassin's Creed
[Music]
thank you
foreign
world of Assassin's Creed there and look
we've had a lot of surprises today I
think that's fair to say but in the
grand tradition of surprises Mack I
think you might have saved the biggest
one for last well Danny that's right
believe it or not I've got more things
to show to you so how about we think a
leap of faith into the future together
let's take a look
oh
my God
[Music]
well I think that's what you call big
news isn't it I mean there's a lot of
stuff in there that I think from your
point of view certainly the community
the fans have been asking for for a long
time so Mac tell us more well this is
code name red our next premium Flagship
title and the future of our open world
RPG games on Assassin's Creed it is
being developed by Ubisoft Quebec the
studio behind Assassin's Creed Odyssey
under the creative direction of Jonathan
sumo it will let players explore one of
their most awaited settings ever on the
franchise funeral Japan and they live a
very powerful Shinobi fantasy I mean
people have been waiting for this for a
long time haven't they yes they have
they certainly have now you brought it
to them it's amazing which is good and
you're slightly cruel in that you're
teasing me with it I very much want that
you mentioned some of the other Studios
uh what's Montreal up to right now well
we have our veteran team behind
Assassin's Creed Valhalla in Montreal
the birthplace of uh Assassin's Creed
who's been hard at work on a new
flagship title as well it is being led
by a creative director Clint Hawking and
is a very different type of Assassin's
Creed game and I believe you may have
brought us something that we can watch
now yes here it is
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
wow the surprises just keep on coming
what can you tell us about this project
well this is codename hexay and I can't
wait for our fans to tear apart that
trailer and find out all its Secrets
yeah absolutely and work out the code
now you guys have always got code names
for stuff that was um was it a year ago
there was codename Infinity where are
you with that well that's a great
question Danny and I'm happy to give you
a little bit more about project Infinity
uh today Infinity is not a game per se
is going to be the single entry point
for our fans into the Assassin's Creed
franchise into the future so you're
saying that players will be able to
explore their very own animus kind of
like a time machine exactly Alice
Infinity is going to be a hub that will
unite all our different experiences and
our players together in meaningful ways
so
obviously that begs the question if
you're connecting players and there's
more than one player a lot of people
will be thinking are we talking
multiplayer well Danny it seems we can't
hide anything from you we're actually
investigating how uh we will bring back
Standalone multiplayer experiences into
the Assassin's Creed Universe all
connected to the infinity Hub well it
sounds extraordinary you must have a nap
at some point because you've all been
very very busy so our thanks Mac some
major new developments there and I'm
sure everyone at home can't wait to get
involved
um thank you for joining us today and
sharing all this incredibly exciting
news well thank you Danny thank you
Alice it's been a pleasure to be here
and to be finally able to share all
these great things that we have coming
for our fans
so to sum up there are a lot of exciting
things to look forward to Let's remind
ourselves of everything you can expect
from now onwards this year we will see
the release of the last chapter to
Abel's story in Assassin's Creed
Valhalla then in 2023 we'll see the
release of the next big title Assassin's
Creed Mirage set in Baghdad and
following the story of Basim from Street
Thief to master assassin
then it's time for the long-awaited
setting of feudal Japan with Assassin's
Creed code name red and as Mac announced
there will also be a very different type
of experience with Assassin's Creed
codename hexay and in the coming years
we'll see the launch of the new platform
Assassin's Creed Infinity connecting
players to the games in a whole new way
but that's not all we'll also see the
launch of our first open world game for
mobile with Assassin's Creed code name
Jade and of course the release of our
live-action Series in partnership with
Netflix so loads to come but that my
friends I'm afraid is all we have time
for today in this very special
Assassin's Creed anniversary showcase
now before I get too comfortable in our
Hideout and end up slipping into my Ezio
cosplay as normal I just want to thank
everyone for joining us today and making
this first ever showcase so special plus
of course a big thank you to our guests
and I shouldn't do this Alice but you
know in the spirit of wrapping up what's
the one thing you're most looking
forward to that's a very tricky question
we've seen so many amazing things
um I'm gonna pick a few okay I will
choose Mirage the Netflix series and
also feudal Japan is that okay that's
fine great
all of you at home remember that you can
pre-order Mirage now in the meantime you
can jump back into Valhalla to prepare
for Evil's last chapter which is exactly
Alice what I'm going to do while we pass
back to Ubisoft forward we will see you
next time
bye-bye goodbye
Leon that was one hell of a show you can
say that again that was one hell of a
show well that does it for this edition
of Ubisoft board we hope you enjoyed it
Yusuf what are you looking for to play
yeah you covered so many great games
today can't wait to play them all well
if you need a reminder of all the
upcoming games featured today head to
our website at ubisoft.com and remember
to grab that free month of Ubisoft plus
you won't want to miss it thank you all
for watching around the globe we'll see
you next time bye
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I'm going home jaw